foreign
let's go to Columbus OH hi oh and talk
to Kim what is up Kim hey Dr John how
are you fantastic how are you
doing good awesome what's up
well I'm calling because
um I'm dating this wonderful man oh
gross gross
and we've been dating a little bit over
a year now and with the holidays coming
up I'm really hoping he proposes
oh I hope he does Just For Humanity's
sake but I hope he doesn't just because
you've built this thing up so good
because here's what happened hey if he
doesn't propose you're gonna feel like
he took something from you and you know
what he took from you everything that's
how you're gonna feel and I'm so excited
about this when my friend I had a friend
who went to uh was going in for like an
annual review and thought that they were
getting a raise of like some crazy
amount of money
and instead of the crazy amount they got
like half of that crazy amount which was
still an insane race
but they felt like someone had taken
that other half from them like you stole
this from me anyway I'm so excited for
you
um do you think it's actually gonna
happen are you just trying to to will
this into existence
well he asked me for my ring size gosh
the guy what happened hey you're done
with him he's out forget this dude he
should have been way smoother I had to
sneak rings from my girlfriend and take
him to the Jewel and be like this is the
size ring she wears
I don't know anyway whatever he's not
very smooth but if he's worth loving
forever then I'll let you have it okay
cool he is all right so okay so what's
your question I'm just talking too much
now what's your question
my question is well well um
okay and so if we were to get engaged or
married I would have to move an hour
away from my family
um the problem is I'm feeling really
guilty about that because I have a 26 or
27 year old brother with special needs
and they my mom and my brother really
depend on me and it should be an
exciting spot but it's just full with
anxiety and what if and
should I mean should I be feeling guilty
about this should I not I just
I think you I think you should feel
really guilty because you're destroying
your family
I'm totally kidding Kim
okay so tell me tell me how
I can't tell you how to feel those your
feelings are just your body trying to
let you know
um there's there's signals for your body
so I can't tell you like you shouldn't
be feeling this or you should be feeling
that what I can tell you is here's how
we're going to process those feelings
how do you you said your parents your
mom and your brother really rely on you
how
um well like I said he's 26 or 27 and he
lives on his own okay and so it was a
transition maybe like um a few years ago
to get him out of my mom's house
and into his own house
and the plan was that my mom and I along
with a few other home health aides who
are fantastic by the way
it was to get him comfortable on his own
and then once he was comfortable with
the other aides we were supposed to
start taking less and less hours fast
forward to two years later I'm still
working full-time helping him out my
mom's still working and the staff we
have now is great but with the shortage
of workers and also he's pretty
particular he's around it's been really
hard to find
other AIDs that match is he autistic I
want to get along with him is he
autistic yes he has autism okay
um I just worked with a lot of folks
with autism so is he
um
well I want to get sidetracked here
is there a chance that this plan y'all
Drew up two years ago was overly
ambitious
and there just needs to be a Reckoning
with reality that needs to happen with
your mom with him with you with
everybody
I mean maybe so okay yes often we get
these plans because we want them to work
out so well right and we especially when
someone struggle with has special needs
um we over we can
we can
over hope that they're going to be able
to figure some things out and it's hard
to read the data back to ourselves in
real time so two years later and you
have not been able to back off the time
investment
two years later you're still not able to
find AIDs that can fully meet his needs
and two years later your mom is still
struggling that tells me that two years
later this idea of him in an autonomous
living situation may not be tenable
it may not be in the cards
right and that's really hard to say out
loud right
yeah it it's really hard but it does
make sense I guess I didn't think about
it because he's been doing better but
then also he hasn't he used to attend a
work program and now he's no longer
attending the work program which means
that we had to find another aid until
that hour for the work program that he
was going to and it just seems like he
just wants to stay home all the time but
the problem is required
he can stay home is that fair
yes you can
no I mean
why why in the world would he go to a
work program if he doesn't have to
right
when he had some very strict access to
people's time and he had to go to the
work program he went right
so let me ask you can I ask you a really
hard personal question
yes how much of his care
and how much of the things that you say
are needs for him are actually ways that
you feel like you are contributing to
him and to your mom
meaning how much of his care is about
you versus how much about him
and this is an accusation this is just I
want you to be honest
what do you mean by that
meaning if you just pull you just
if you just extracted yourself and moved
an hour away with your new husband
that may or may not happen by the way
um you just packed up and moved
would his life come crashing to us to a
halt
would your mom have to figure out other
alternative arrangements and then all of
a sudden you give it two or three months
after some fits and stops and starts
and then he's just moved on without you
and that feels as devastating as
watching him struggle
um
fear is
many more yeah I would be the cause for
him to no longer be able to live on his
own in an apartment setting and he would
have to go more into a group setting
and you you have not given me any
indication that he's going to do
anything other than have a group
situation
right
because right now you're propping him up
right
is that fair
tell me again I don't want to be harsh
but I've spent 20 years having hard
conversations with family members about
young people with special needs
and you just I mean we have to say like
here's the here's the here's the truth
to the situation
why is why do you feel like you have
failed him if he ends up going to a
group home
where you can have direct access Direct
Care he can have Community he can have
um
people who are trained in why do you
feel like you'd be failing him
I don't know I don't know where that
comes from let me ask you a hardware
question why do you feel like when you
have joy
that you're somehow taking something
from him
because I think you're scared to get
married because you're scared to move on
with your life a life that he can't have
and there's a part of you that feels
guilty about that
yeah and you know what now that you said
it out loud that does make a lot of
sense
and I think that gill also comes from my
mom
because they know that she'll be alone
and it feels like I'm moving on not
moving on I'll always be in connection
with my family I'm not gonna you know
fall off the face of the Earth on them
but
I
yeah I guess I I feel like they do
better when
I'm I'm just around
with them I bet that's true I bet they
their life is easier and I bet there's
more joy and I bet
um things just go better when you're
around there's no doubt in my mind
because you're an amazing young woman
and you're You're such you care deeply
for your mom you could deeply for your
brother
the one person you've left out of this
whole equation is Kim
and you've managed to like
piecemeal a romantic relationship
together on the side here
um
in on top of your duties of working
full-time and taking care of your
brother full-time so that your mom could
fill in the blank so that your brother
could fill in the blank all of this is
about propping up a fantasy that's not
real
your mom had a different picture of what
her life would look like and she has a
special needs 26 year old son
you've given her an amazing opportunity
to not have to deal with that
directly but at some point she will
and you're right and your brother who
sounds like he's like a fun loving like
he's a lovely guy he's got a lot of
challenges but he's fun he's cool
or you would want to spend that much
time with him
you had a picture of those people who
sent their kids or their brothers to
those places
and you don't want to be in if you see
all this comes back to you
you don't want people to judge you in
the way that you judge other people
right and so I will tell you you're
worth having a really rambunctious
Reckless Love
and you're worthy of getting married and
if you gotta move you gotta move
and also you really need to sit down
with your fiance your maybe fiance and
have the conversation here's what kind
of sister I am
my mom and dad pass he's going to live
in a home in our neighborhood or around
us or my goal is within 10 years I want
to have a house with a back apartment on
it that we can have a nurse so I want
you to know this is the kind of sister I
am
or we gonna support him financially
because when my mom passes away we're
not going to have any money we're not
going to have she doesn't have a Special
Needs Trust built like we'll be really
sober minded and clear-eyed about these
things
but the idea that you can what you're
going to do is you're going to end up
avoiding guilt for so long you're going
to resent your brother
and you're going to resent your mom and
then you're going to resent you for
feeling resentment over those two people
and your husband's gonna present you for
feeling like he's in third place all the
time and your kids are going to resent
because they don't know where you see
what I'm saying choose guilt over
resentment every single time
and do it with dignity and respect
meaning if you just pack up and leave
without a Runway that's pretty not cool
but letting folks know hey we're getting
engaged which means we're going to be
married in the next year which means at
some point I'm going to be moving Mom we
have to have a conversation a very true
and real conversation about transition
because this isn't working
okay is that fair
it is it's just hard tell me tell me why
it's hard
it's hard because I know everyone's
gonna be upset
when did it become your job to make sure
other people weren't upset
because man that's an exhausting role
it's not but oh you said it you said it
you said it it's not your job
okay now I'm also somebody who
um
I believe in taking care of your family
I really do probably more so than is is
makes sense and I believe in taking care
of the least of these in our communities
much less in our homes okay so your life
may look different you may never get
that Lexus you may be a Camry family
forever because you're saving the money
up to pay for your brother's care or for
uh home health nurse or whatever
you may never have a five bedroom house
on 30 acres and whatever thing you dream
about you may be a three bedroom two
bath house even when you have three kids
like so making peace with some of these
things in the short term
will give you so much peace in the long
term
it's just being honest and intentional
about it all does that make sense
yeah it makes a lot of sense here's
where I would start I would start with a
conversation with your mom
say mom in in 2023 I'm hoping to get
engaged from this knuckleheaded whatever
guy
um I'm hoping engaged we need to have a
hard conversation about brother because
his the plan we put in place is just not
working
so we need to plan either he's going to
move back home with you
and we're going to get some AIDS and
nursing help here or we need to start
looking at group homes and we got a year
out
um and you need to have a secondary
conversation with the person who before
they ask you Miriam and and hopefully
you've had this conversation but we're
gonna have a very direct conversation
about hey here's the kind of sister I am
and part of marrying me part of loving
me forever
is
um I'm a sister who takes care of her
brother when he can't take care of
himself
and we're gonna be very honest about the
finances we're going to be very honest
about our boundaries and
most important you got to put your
oxygen mask on first Kim
taking care of you isn't selfish
taking care of you isn't a somehow a
violation of your mom's love or your
brother's love
you take care of Kim
you make sure Kim has great
relationships and that Kim's body is
taken care of with good food and sleep
and with exercise you take care of you
that you got good a good job so that
you've got something firm that you can
anchor into and repel off the side and
then take care of the other people in
your life
otherwise man you find yourself just
flying in the wind like a kite trying to
take care of everybody all the time
and that's not sustainable and it ends
up in ashes every time
or you end up 58 years old and you're
bitter and you're upset and you resent
and you look back on your life and say
yeah
I don't want that for you I want that
for your family I don't want that for
your brother I don't want that for
anybody
so let's go all the way back to the to
the beginning here and say let's have
some hard conversations
oh
let's be honest about am I doing this
for me am I doing this for my brother
and let's be honest about what our
marriage is going to look like
and when you get engaged call me call me
we'll do a big announcement here on the
show because I'm excited for you it's
gonna be rad thank you for trusting us
and um for walking with me Kim uh good
luck to you we'll talk to you soon